we got this from the post-millennial
breaking Biden has cancerous tissue
removed from chest a statement from the
president's physician announced that
Biden had a skin lesion on his chest
removed at Walter Reed hospital in DC
which was later tested and found to be
basal cell carcinoma a type of skin
cancer all right so that's the that's
the news you may be asking because I
don't want I don't want to bury this I
don't want to come out and be like he's
dying yes cancer no no hold on
this is the Kelowna skin cancer center
clinic
Kelowna Skin Cancer Clinic I just looked
this up is basal cell carcinoma fatal
they say no
the risk of death is extremely low
however it has the potential to cause
significant disfigurement and that can
have a serious impact on your life the
prognosis is excellent so it's not like
Joe Biden is on his deathbed or anything
like that but the reason I think this is
this is important is because we had this
story a while ago where in July on July
22nd 2022 Joe Biden said he had cancer
he said where is it at he has his quote
here and he says you had to put on your
windshield wipers again literally oil
stick off the window that's why I and so
damn many other people I grew up grew up
with have cancer and why can for the
longest time Delaware the highest cancer
rate in the nation
when he said that the media was like no
no no he meant he had it he had it well
apparently he didn't
I mean apparently this dude has
consistently had cancerous lesions on
his skin so I don't know
it's it's breaking news do you guys
think it's significant well I'm not
president has cancer it's definitely
significant I don't think it's it's not
surprising because he did tell us he had
cancer like last year but then the media
was like no no no also it's probably not
super uncommon for people that are you
know his age and in that kind of
stressful environment to develop some
sort of reaction stress reaction like I
think cancer can be brought in by stress
and diet as much as like I don't know if
Pharma is going to tell you it's brought
on by but a lot of times fixing your
diet can in my opinion skin cancer is
usually a product of sun exposure
usually but um yeah it's another like an
environmental stressor as well yeah
sorry to interrupt you no no it just
like my dad passed away at cancer and
like 20 years ago and it was melanoma
it's
you know it's not typical for people to
die but Joe Biden is from from skin
cancer but Joe Biden is old you know so
I I don't know that that this is is
something that is gonna often
but I imagine it's worth being honest
with the American people about I think
the biggest issue here is the fact that
again the media is is you know playing
doing the the pr role for the
administration remember that story about
Biden being in the shower and then
trying to trying to grab the dog's tail
and then slipping and breaking his foot
or whatever yeah yeah yeah everybody you
know uh watches everybody but a lot of
people thought that was cover for
something else so they could get him
into the hospital
oh he hurt his foot he's got to go to
the hospital and then really they were
doing the timeline on that on how long
he's in the hospital for yeah or like I
don't know when he was in I'm curious I
don't know but I mean if if they can go
in and remove cancerous tissue that
quickly I wonder if they've like they're
at the point where they're just like
look we can't pretend anymore like yeah
we just got to tell people the truth
this it's not the first time he's had
cancer removed but I don't know I'm just
the crazy thing is
at first I see the story about Biden
having cancer and I'm like okay well
it's serious no matter how serious the
cancer is but then I just think nobody
who
likes Joe Biden well nobody likes Joe
Biden but nobody who was on the left or
liberal cares the dude could like have a
heart attack on stage and they'd be like
well you know uh and then make an excuse
for it and then people on the right
don't believe he's actually in charge
anyway
so does anybody really care that Biden's
I do I care I don't like him but I care
for about him and I mean I mean
politically like is there any concern at
all so I he's an 80 year old man and I
understand many people in the audience
aren't the biggest fans of Joe Biden but
I think we should be praying for this
man given that if he plots then it's
Kamala Harris so it's only getting worse
from here and it's going to get a lot
worse people think Joe Biden's
incompetent I think Kamal Harris is
twice as incompetent as Joe Biden so we
should be praying for this age-old man
Joe Biden used to know some stuff Kamala
Harris has never known a thing ever
and yeah they're still trying to drop
her there's been a lot of beef between
um Biden and Kamal so I'd be keeping an
eye on her if anything because if
something happens to Biden uh I'd be
nervous that Kamal was involved yeah or
a sick Biden like a really not well guy
is makes way poorer decisions like an
unhealthy mind is the most dangerous
President we could have I don't care who
it is if someone's got a broken brain so
I want him to become healthy and soak in
the top guys there's an old saying that
the Apple doesn't fall too far from the
tree and so when you look at Hunter
Biden as a human being you have to
wonder about his dad I was like I wanna
I wanna help I want to like these people
to become healthier I want Vladimir's
Lindsey to become healthier I want
Vladimir Putin to become healthier and
then I was like I want the Russian
soldier and the Ukrainian soldier that
are shooting at each other to both
become healthier and then I was
picturing two guys in a knife fight and
trying to get them to both become
healthier and I'm like I couldn't
stop at some point I can't heal both of
them when they're killing each other
that's right
you can't heal one
like I can't I don't know who to like I
do want to like
Elevate and heal people but when they're
it's like I can't it's I couldn't like
spiritually do it I was like there's
some sort of uh blockade like blur so I
have an idea here I think there's
something wrong what I think we see
sometimes in politics is where we they
push politicians who are unhealthy to
continue running and continue their role
because there's a lot of people attached
to them and I think we saw that in the
case with I don't know exactly what's
going on with Dianne Feinstein but she
has shingles and she probably should
have retired a long time ago Joe Biden
doesn't seem totally competent John
fetterman probably didn't need to finish
running that campaign after he had the
stroke but it seemed that he was
pressured by his wife and others um
Chrissy what do you think about this
stuff yeah it's just I was thinking that
the whole Biden thing is so reminiscent
of what's going on with John fetterman I
just I genuinely know talking about this
with Ashley the other day too like
there's no way that man just has
depression there has to be something
else he's got to be covering up for
something else
um but at the same time you know I
counted it or counteract myself because
I'm like there's no way his wife just
left a man that could be dying of
something to go to Canada unless she's
like a Stepford Wife you know like yeah
I get it though because if John's if
he's incapacitated and the kids are
probably so scared for their dad and so
they're like let's do something fun yeah
it's not an agriculture so it wasn't
like they went to the Deep runaway it's
New York you know Niagara Falls right
now I'm thinking though like think about
your spouse is running in a primary they
have a stroke they aren't in the best of
health and the campaign is not an easy
thing to run there's a lot of pressure
it's a lot of stress reporters are
hounding you I was one of the reporters
hounding them and she was like no let's
stay in the race through the general and
one of the most contentious elections
the Senate races it's an extremely close
Senate race and that takes a toll on
your health so you have to think about
like what a lot of these people around
them are putting some of these
politicians through and you have to
worry if if Joe Biden is okay and again
we're praying that he is because if he
does plot or resign it's not getting
better I don't know I don't I don't know
if I I think it'll be that different
I think Kamala Harris has a different
team around here I think they're
completely
do you think Kamala Harris has a team I
mean yeah and I think she has a
different team around her that
that she's incompetent like she also did
very poorly across the country when she
was running for president I don't even
think she pulled well in California she
quit she quit before the California
primary so that way she didn't get so
she didn't get hosed and lose her entire
political career because she was gonna
she was gonna get trout in California by
Andrew Yang yeah I couldn't imagine
Kamala Harris interacting with different
world leaders too in a serious way she'd
just have that nervous laugh I don't
trust her with her hands on the Nuclear
One
I think that I'm kind of whether it's
Trump I mean I think Trump would do a
good job
but I gotta be honest you know we're
going to talk a little bit later about
this these uh this cat lady burning down
her house and then I just think about it
and I'm just like
maybe we just need some hard times man
I think we'll all be fine I think
everybody who listens to a show like
this is probably fine we got so many
people who are like look I bought
chickens I got got out of the city and
I'm just like I think most people will
be fine
and I think the reality is I wouldn't
want to pull a Bill Maher and be like
bring on the recession to get rid of
trump
but I would want to say something like
guys whether you want it to or not the
storm is a bruin and we can see the
clouds off on the horizon whether it
comes now or whether it comes tomorrow
you best get ready for it but you know
what that storm is going to come and
wash away all of all this BS I've toyed
with the idea of let it get worse sooner
so that it can get better faster I don't
think it really works that way if you
let things get bad they get really bad
and out of control when things are out
of control the world economic Forum
creates a new government I'm not saying
to let things go to control I'm saying
brace yourself for the storm and I'm
saying whether it's Biden or Kamala that
storm's coming either way but let's
let's weather the storm the thing is
with tip from to Tim's point the more
people you have prepared for hard times
and for the storm or whatever like the
less impact the people have on the
people that are unprepared so the more
people you have that are prepared the
more capable they are of helping the
people that are unprepared so it's it's
just a good idea idea to you know have
some kind of ability to have to to fend
for yourself have some food stored up
you know have have a week or two maybe a
couple months depending on your your
ability you know but I'm just a lot of
people have chickens how do you defend
your chickens what's the best defense
electric fence uh mil-spec AR-15 like
actual guard on duty other Beyond a
guard under the electric fence thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time